I also want to make amends to you baby
today no it's about something that did
last well tell me and I want before I
bring it up
are you sure you want to be here yeah
he's gonna be here I'm here man my
assault I'm actually the counselor okay
I don't want you to get angry you
promise you won't get angry I don't know
I don't promise anything
just [ __ ] promise you won't be angry
but can I physically assault you no you
can't touch me that would be anger
that's true it could just it could
physical assault can come from many
different emotions I'm gonna say it okay
I never saw on meros perros you [ __ ]
oh what's that so four months she was
like you know righteous about the types
of these movies that he's seen - sure
ammo foo and Kurosawa oh you've never
seen the Seven Samurai he just he sits
on this [ __ ] high horse and he tells
everybody around him how stupid they are
for not having seen these classics or
these movies by these directors right so
I told him I was like hey like have you
seen a moto sparrows which is bi can you
say in English it's a movie and he goes
oh yeah I've seen that of course I've
seen this no no I know I didn't say that
listen shut the [ __ ] up all right
she goes I go I haven't seen it and she
goes well you gonna watch it tonight I
don't want to watch it tonight I want to
do other things I want to watch
Westworld know you're watching it and so
when she was in the shower right I
Wikipedia it all right and I read the
synopsis right and I memorized it as
much as I could and then when she came
back I cleared my history on my iPad she
said that she didn't know that I was
Wikipedia and she looked at her sister
to see if you don't know so I bought the
movie we're laying it sitting next to
each other and it starts I go wait does
this movie have like a dogs as a theme
she goes yeah I go is this like three or
four stories combined she goes yeah I
guess the sex I go is the second story
have to do with like model and like a
guy that movie
oh just so you couldn't sit through an
hour a movie that your girlfriend in LA
I said I'll watch it if you want me to
you know you don't watch it now I would
have enjoyed it I'm sorry and I'm never
gonna see it I'm never good movie well
it's your loss all right smile it's a
great [ __ ] movie that guy in the
closet yeah well yeah yeah yeah where's
Brice was somebody knocking downstairs
maybe
no or no yeah but I'm not gonna watch it
it's okay but are you mad at me no no
it's a funny though it actually crossed
my mind that you would Wikipedia that
[ __ ] cuz that's something you would do
you lazy [ __ ] it's a good movie I know
all right all right all right look
you're not mad no I'm not a master all
right let me ask you is he getting laid
tonight
probably not Michael huh go ahead
probably not yeah I have some old DVD
Smallville's I might have some of those
too though do you believe that I met her
on tinder I can't believe she's
beautiful I mean I'm not the girls
aren't beautiful who are on tinder yeah
it's starting to kick in I'm allergic to
his [ __ ] cats other died here I love
that oh really no you really are you
like feeling it right now I feel better
to breathe okay but before you weren't
you know what art in the field I think
you gotta be around pet cats to get over
up right is that what you said - yeah
dairy the to get over lactose
intolerance you have a little bit of
dairy every day really so if you could
have buried my pants every day yeah you
are winning so
well you were about to get into
something nobody what I'm saying is is
that the tender yeah I forgot what I was
gonna say actually well you believe that
you'd met her on Timbo that's what I did
say that yeah yeah I did say that but
the ugliest weirdest picture up or
something right ya know for me
ya know I I have a theory of with tinder
and I think it works every time
what is the theory well especially when
it comes to like cuz Eric Stonestreet
and where I told him to get on tinder
and he did it for like a little bit
right and I went to his house is to
teach him and so I had you got to put
you know your are the best shot like a
head shot of you right and everyone sees
it Eric Stonestreet but then you do
other photos right of him like working
or with fridge just having fun right and
and I do that with other people too that
aren't in show business have a photo of
me take a photo with me and we're having
fun right so then maybe they know that I
was the guy I would never let you curate
this in there yeah yeah these things
bother me I've only been on one dating
site which one I can't really I could
just say it yeah it's it's a celebrity
brand right now I can't say it I can't
say it because there's a reason I can't
say I have a friend that works on one of
them whatever and I was the only one I
ever did I finally got on it it's Riya
but we do any of these things is they
never look like the [ __ ] picture you
see meaning it's I'm gonna give you a
picture at my worst be maybe it one
that's cuter but then you see these
pictures and first of all it's it's
always this more a photo of just their
dog I like that no I don't like that if
a guy just I'm not gonna [ __ ] your dog
sure I will swipe right yeah I'm just
but here's the issue I've shown up
before and I was like the girl comes up
I go have you seen this girl yeah you
guys careful of this angle anytime it's
a downward angle it's never it's she's
conscious about her body
i if all the photos are from the [ __ ]
shoulders out right and I pee before you
I picked up a girl I'm not gonna name
her name well it's a wide shot it's like
an official ends right and that this
girl had Natalie Portman's face but she
had Michael Chiklis his body like it was
like a Boston cop said that when she
came down the stairs and I have a Prius
I try to go forward but he didn't move
for some reason and then she got in the
car okay so what would you prefer then a
pretty face or a scepter head
everything's good scepter head see do
you want a butter face I just want I
just want a picture someone I'm gonna
see in about a day or two yeah just be
something like the assembling so yes
person I think that's a fair request
it's not fair yeah that's there to go
there and it's like you know yeah you
can't like face I'm a big face fan how
about this did your big faces really
which I don't have all his exes have
like really long banana faces really yes
no they're pretty banana faces they're
pretty girls you talk about their
[ __ ] beef curtains all day long I'm
saying they have just bananas yeah what
kind of a Chavez do you like vaginas
yeah you like all styles you know I
think there was a phase where everybody
liked to clean you know yeah you know I
got one rule I'm really weird about
smells I could yeah I could smell a bala
jerk are from what I'm a river cool
yeah but I just like smells got
everything smell good that's it I
thought it looks you know it looks good
and tidy you know that's great you know
if it smell good but it looked like the
Kraken from like class of the Titans
you'd be fine with it oh no I don't want
the cracker average vagina it smelled
nice that's good yes really smells good
it's a you know I don't mind a little
hair and hairs coming back it's all hair
now and not just hair that stays in the
bikini line it's everywhere it's like no
out of their panties stop that
that's what then I swear to God the
Gallagher's in now what have you hooked
up with a girl she had no hair but then
she had a little hair in the inside
would that be a sillier like in the
canal inside the vagina yeah that's
impossible there are only a few places
in your body that doesn't have hair and
one of is the inside of the cavernous
vagina how do you feel about hairy
nipples
I have hairy nipples where I have three
strays on each nipple very important
when I pluck them out does it hurt
most girls do we just never tell you we
pluck them yeah each fuzz is one thing
you know how you like peachy I know I'm
just saying if you saw a breast in the
let light you know during the day blonde
hair and you see little blonde hairs
across it you know I mean and it's like
flowing I like that but if it's like
Harry and the Hendersons you don't mean
like full-on hair yeah like if you're in
Glendale you know I mean if you go to
the waxing areas there the Armenian
girls do wax your chest take care of it
it works their chest and I just want to
say to Armenians I love you guys right
out there I love you guys when I was in
Israel we went and saw where
mania is not Israel I understand that
but they had the art that genocide there
oh that's right they had the monument
yeah yeah so I went a bit more yeah I
had a little tears in my eyes so and you
don't have heritage so it's just
something that I said
[Music]